patrick est porteur de handicap
psychique depuis 2009 il est accueilli
au foyer d'accueil occupationnel de
l'association aleph pas à saint-leu ici
occupationnel ne signifie pas passer le
temps depuis son arrivée patrick s'est
fixé plusieurs objectifs avec l'équipe
du afao des objectifs qui convergent
vers l'acquisition de la plus grande
autonomie possible l'uefa est un foyer
d'accueil occupationnel il ya deux sites
dont il ya le site de saluer le site de
saint paul donc actuellement nous sommes
sur le site de saint leu qui accueille
15 adultes en situation d'handicap
essentiellement des personnes
déficientes intellectuelles avec des
troubles associés
l'objectif c'est le travail et sur
l'autonomie ne te demi dans les actes de
la vie quotidienne l'autonomie au niveau
de l'hygiène l'autonomie également posté
atteint en fonction de leurs besoins ben
autonomie au niveau du transport en
fonction des besoins qu'on a repéré va
émerger des objectifs de travail et à
partir de là eh ben on va mettre en
place des activités pour atteindre les
objectifs cette année l'objectif fixé et
la préparation à l'intégration d'un
établissement de service d'aidé par le
travail un esat si sa préférence penche
pour l'hygiène et la maintenance des
locaux il faut s'habituer aux tâches
qu'il devra être en capacité d'exercer
toutes font partie d'un apprentissage
global ce matin on démarre par un stage
de jardinage toutes les activités qui
sont à part sont dans un but bien précis
mais aussi à dans le but de faire
évoluer les usagers dans différents
domaines moi en l'occurrence là où jadis
le jardin c'est aussi pour permettre
aussi de transposer ce qu'on fait aussi
quelques fois à un web os chez eux par
exemple aujourd'hui vont apprendre
comment ils vont planter les oignons
comme ont pris part à d'abord couper les
oignons les préparer comment les mets 31
et ensuite après suite à cela il y aura
aussi l'entretien comment remuer la
terre autour de saison que cela puisse
grandir vraiment des expériences vont
faire lui permettre d'aborder plus
facilement les apps il est très actif et
c'est vrai il veut tellement les vite
que des fois
les consignes les comportements 100%
considération la vidéo d'époque si même
le travail était le fait qu'il passe un
petit peu à côté du consignes donc ça
répond pas trop trop au travail demandé
donc avec lui je travaille sur tout ça
il a des bonnes capacités il est il est
courageux il est motivé
et comme il veut vraiment les adh donc
c'est un plus on n'a pas besoin vraiment
de
pousser on est là pour le motiver
l'encourager mais il a d'abord en
premier lieu un désir de lire les
attaques
pourquoi mes amis m
pourquoi hier l'agent
c'est ensuite l'heure de la cuisine en
esat c'est un secteur porteur il prend
les initiatives
il sait quand il faut venir mais le
couvert et remplit les brodeau a fait
remonter dans le frigo
il sait déjà faire tout ça et on n'a pas
besoin de lui dire de se laver de les
mains à chaque fois chaque service il
faut qu'il se lave les mains il met les
gants pour faire le ménage
pour moi je vois que pourra avancer vers
l'avenir ça va prendre du temps mais ça
viendra la motivation doit être
entretenu cet accompagnement fait partie
d'une démarche positive
patrick s'exerce enfin son activité
favorite pour le moment l'hygiène et la
maintenance des locaux on va faire un
diagnostic de besoin au départ et on va
pas forcément se baser sur les
difficultés ou les points qui posent
réellement problème on va partir des
points positifs les personnes qui sont
en situation de handicap c'est déjà
difficile pour eux d'accepter leur
handicap si en plus on leur pointe les
points négatifs va ça va être plus
difficile pour eux d'avancer alors qu'en
travaillant à partir des points positifs
et ben c'est valorisant pour eux et on
s'est rendu compte que baye des
évolutions les évolutions positives bien
qu'ils soient majeurs patrick est sous
tutelle de sa mère pour valider ce
projet d'orientation en esat formulée
par patrick cela nécessite son accord au
delà de l'aspect juridique c'est un
soutien psychologique important ben je
pense que si comme lille veut
fait ce stage
papier comme ça mais la confiance en lui
que 2 pourra faire son stage s'il avait
fait
même la signer le contrat d fait son
stage la famille c'est un partenaire
primordial dans notre relation le rôle
de la famille c'est à dire que les
projets qu'on va proposer mettre en
place ici c'est la continuité en famille
ce à dire que ce qu'on fait ici et aussi
travailler en famille le cap de cette
année 2015 est fixé pour patrick avec
l'accompagnement de sa famille et du fmi
ils gagnent chaque jour en autonomie et
avec un emploi à la clé il volera
bientôt peut-être de ses propres ailes